We can also use frames to address the Raven's Matrices problems that we
have been talking about all throughout this course. In fact as we do so
we'll note another interesting fact, frames in semantic networks are closely
related. So let's do this problem. Here is a particular image and
here is a semantic network for this particular image that we had come across
earlier. I could rewrite this semantic network in the language of frames. But,
first of all building a frame for each of these specific objects.
I have frame for x, a frame for y and a frame for z. So, here are the frames for
the three objects, x, y and z. Let's look at the frame for z in more detail for
just a second. So, here are the slots, the name is z,
the shape is a circle the size is small and it is filled, you can see it here.
We can also capture the relationship between these two objects. So
let's consider a relationship example. Here y is inside x, y is inside x.
We can capture that through this slot for the object y. Here is the slot for
inside, for the object y, and it is pointing to x, indicating that y is
inside x. Note again the equivalence between the semantic network and
the frame representations. The three objects and the three
frames corresponding to three objects. The relationship between the objects and
the relationships being captured by these blue lines here between the frames.
While we can capture relationships between frames through lines like this where
one frame points to another frame, we could also capture them more directly by
actually specifying variables of other frame names. So for example, for
the frame y, we might say, inside x which captures the same idea that we
were capturing by drawing a line between them. In fact,
this is a notation we'll use with the rest of the exercises in this lesson.